it's coming up on 5 44. on your
wednesday morning what's driving you
crazy well there's a
signal that the northwest valley is
really
growing the city of las vegas has
announced seven
new traffic signals for the area with
construction on the first one
starting monday it's at farm road in oso
blanca city says
that should be ready for traffic by the
end of march
then two more get started on uh in march
oso blanca and grand
montecito there's also one going to be
going in at grand teton and
hualapai and those should be good to go
sometime
in may now in april you want to look for
work crews at grand teton and grand
canyon
with the signal ready in june all right
in june we're going to start on a signal
at farm road in grand canyon with
completion set for
august now the last two new signals will
be
starting in july at deer springs and
grand canyon
as well as centennial parkway and fort
apache with completion in september or
october
you don't have to write all this stuff
down it is on our website
eightnewsnow.com
with a lot more other information about
these projects just click traffic then
driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if something's driving
you crazy
go ahead and email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com